the Joe Rogan experience I got a little
apartment with some stash there you have
a couple safes you have to if the cops
ain't gonna let you deposit it you got
to be [ __ ] creative if you read all
these guys stories the hardest and
you're open you ready for this
expression the hardest thing is what to
do think about that problem Joe Masseria
now it's a real problem
no no think about this room what was the
movie I just want oh come on oh no no no
I just on a plane you come when you're
on a plane and Tom Cruise's on you got
to give him the benefit of the doubt
oh I got an edible in me I watched the
Barry seal thing how was it it's not an
Academy Award winner but it's very
interesting when we're just burying
money child wrote it for million is shot
it means you are the yard like burying
money like a suitcase with hundra now
the bills falling out of it and you
don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ] I always
wanted to know this Snopes this did
Barry seal die with George Bush's phone
number in his pocket that's a we said
and he died they shot him on the way to
the trial what George Bush's phone
number in his pocket no he was top notch
that guy he had it all he's seen it bro
he took pictures of them loading a
[ __ ] plane in Nicaragua with Escobar
and the top aid in Nicaragua they had
him by the [ __ ] balls no matter what
how you that took balls [ __ ] can't they
[ __ ] him in the ass they told that
they wouldn't release the pictures yeah
then they released the pictures
resolution that's why I think I got shot
as [ __ ] up they should have taken him
and hit me [ __ ] is interesting no they
assassinated that guy that's a 100%
assassination in connection to some sort
of illegal government it was the [ __ ]
about that was Escobar that said I
buried a message they had a deal where
Barry keels could land though right like
that wasn't part of the thing was with
the people on the ground on the ground
that was in me no but here's the problem
this is where Eddie Bravo comes in right
they were landing in those Everglades
and don't quote me on this
and he broke it down for me and somebody
else broke it down me to be honest with
you and they were allowing that on your
boys clock Clinton come on that's that's
that's ladies always be his drops out
right because the truth is fascinating
the truth is two boys were murdered and
the coroner the official report they
gave to the parents was that they had
fallen asleep on the train tracks so the
parents pay for some sort of an autopsy
and it's revealed that the kid had been
stabbed and that one of them had been
stabbed and then they find out that
around that same area was where those
guys would drop their drugs before they
landed they would parachute down their
drugs they would they would like and
they would land and these guys they
would drop points where they would put
their [ __ ] and then someone else would
come by and pick it up on the ground
yeah Gordon right and these kids
apparently saw something they weren't
supposed to see so they [ __ ] murdered
these kids with knives and then the
coroner was all in on it so they had to
conduct some sort of independence so
that is what got this whole Barry seals
things going it was this lady trying to
figure out this parents trying to figure
out what happened to their kids don't
just [ __ ] crazy story you have to
imagine okay that these guys were
getting you know let's just draw a
number I mean I'm just an idiot but
let's just draw no but they were
probably $4,000 per kilo
what would they put on those planes and
then we're sending five of those planes
over a day and dropping them in
Louisiana this one listen and my told
you a thousand times of the podcast in
they found the bear dead next to a
duffel bag filled with cocaine in Aspen
Colorado in the mountains because they
were dropping the [ __ ] coke in the
mountain say okay Barry seal seal had
organized a sting operation where he
managed to get photographs of Pablo
Escobar helping Nicaraguan soldiers to
lo twelve hundred kilos of cocaine onto
a seat
please soon afterwards Reagan went on
television with the photograph to
denounce Sandinistas as drug smuggling
corrupting dhak dhak that's how much he
was getting for that four million eight
hundred thousand he was for one [ __ ]
load now here's the tricky bit here's
what here's what really pisses me the
[ __ ] off that I see narcos and I see
everything but now this is your uncle
Joey talking to you Joe Rogan please
show me a good side of Pablo Escobar no
no no no no there's no good side to
Pablo Escobar this ain't Lee Harvey
Weinstein this is a story that we have
never brought up but you have to assume
okay you you see all these shows and the
whole [ __ ] thing and they were in bed
for sure with Nicaragua let me ask you
this you think that it is the actual CIA
or is it people or if when it was let's
not even say CIA DEA FBI made a bunch of
[ __ ] letters put them together is it
the actual organization whichever one it
is that's bringing it in
are they complicit or are there just
Cowboys see the theories always been
that there's been these few Cowboys
corrupt guys maybe they get too close to
drug deals too close to the drug deal
and then sometimes they get seduced like
there's many many stories of under kind
of undercover cops getting seduced by
the actual lifestyle of being a criminal
young kids they probably did a little
crime themselves here there they see
some cops doing some dirty [ __ ] they see
him some guy you know there was a thing
that came out about was it Baltimore
what is the city where cops had it came
out in trial they had kept toy guns on
them to plant at the scene of a crime
like if they just decide she's a [ __ ]
toy we're talking in a big picture the
big world picture as an intelligent
individual as you are the plant it was
plain and simple the CIA wanted a piece
of their action and the DEA was tricked
into going down in a really controller
war you can't be this and I'm not saying
you as an American you can't be this
dumb so all the research that we've done
right all the research that we've done
we
general north he was in on the pledge
with battery seal the whole [ __ ]
thing in his woods gets even deeper
let's talk about the deep to subject
that nobody ever even looked at and you
have to think of because I heard this
story a thousand times there was a guy
by the name is Carlos laid there doctor
that he got crazy you know they show him
getting his dick sucked on the radio in
Colombia and everything and all these TV
shows no he was on an island snorting
coke with long hair talking like Jim
Morrison and having [ __ ] threesomes
and the [ __ ] their own cartel gave
laid they're up to the law there to keep
them off their back it was five partners
it's me you Jamie and red band but
[ __ ] red bands out there doing videos
of him snorting coke with a [ __ ]
pigeon on his head we can't have this
they gave the DEA [ __ ] Carlos that
come gonna calm things down for a while
when Dan 83 and 84 when Reagan sent his
troops down there don't quote me on the
dates here
but I will tell you as a professional
cocaine sniffer what was going on in 85
the price of cocaine went skyrocketing
and it was in the head room second
thought it wasn't because of cocaine
skyrocketing it was because the cocaine
was coming in but the toughest part was
getting the ether alcohol into Colombia
to process it
the Colombians had got a tip that did
they were the troops for coming down to
raid their jungles now what they had not
told you in all these shows and research
but this is wrong Kildonan op on you is
where do you think they took one other
they took some labs to Nicaragua and
they shipped cocaine out of Nicaragua
but guess who else partnered up with
them to your buddy sit down sit down was
shipping it in yeah he's gonna be on the
podcast in three weeks
can you imagine having $4 you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and Fidel you were truly my god
this whole block would have snipers and
[ __ ] everybody Fidel just walked in
would assume
and you had a teach him like a UFC movie
ships
[Laughter]
[Applause]